PROFESSOR: If we're going to
make use of Chebyshev's Bound
and other results that
depend on the variance,
we'll need some methods
for calculating variance
in various circumstances.
So let's develop that here.
A basic place to begin is
to ask about the indicator
variables and their variance.
Remember, i is an
indicator variable that
means that it's zero one value.
It's also called the
Bernoulli variable.
And if the probability
that it equals 1 is p,
that's also its expectations.
So we have an indicator
variable with expectation
of the indicator is
p, and we're asking
what's its variance, which by
definition is the expectation
of i minus p squared.
Well, this is one of the sort
of almost mechanical proofs that
follows simply by algebra
and linearity of expectation.
But let's walk through
it step by step,
just to reassure you that
that's all that's involved.
I would recommend against
really trying to memorize this,
because it's-- I can
remember it anyway,
I just reprove it
every time I need it.
And so, let's see how
the proof would go.
So step one would be
to expand this i minus
p squared algebraically.
So we're talking about the
expectation of i squared
minus 2pi plus p squared.
Now we can just apply
linearity of expectation,
and I get the expectation
of i squared minus 2p times
the expectation of
i plus p squared.
Of course, the expectation of
a constant is the constant.
So when I take expectation of
p squared, I get p squared.
But now look at this.
i squared is zero one value.
So in fact, i squared is equal
to i and the expectation of i
has now appeared here, that's p.
So this term simplifies
to expectation of i,
and this term becomes 2p
times p plus p squared.
Of course that
expectation of i is a p.
So I've got p minus 2p
squared plus p squared.
The p squareds cancel, and
I get p minus p squared.
If you factor out p,
that's p times 1 minus p,
or pq, which is the
standard way that you
write the variance of
an indicator variable.
It's p times 1 minus p.
OK, that was easy, and
again, completely mechanical.
There's a couple of other
rules for calculating
variance of new variables
from old ones that are basic.
Like [? additivity ?]
of expectation,
but it doesn't quite work
so simply for variance.
So the first rule
is that if you ask
about the variance
of a constant times r
plus b, that turns out to
be the same as a squared
times the variance of b-- of r.
The b doesn't-- the additive
of be doesn't matter,
and the-- because the variance
is really the expectation
of something squared, when
you get rid of that constant
a, you're factoring
out an squared.
And this is the
rule you get here.
OK.
Another basic rule that's
often convenient, instead
of working with variance in the
form of the expectation of r
minus mu squared,
is to say that it's
the expectation of r
squared minus the square
of the expectation of r.
Now, this expression-- the
square of the expectation of r
comes up so often that
there's a shorthand for it.
Where instead of
writing [? parends ?]
you write e squared of
r, just means the same
as expectation of r squared.
And so much for the second rule,
which we'll use all the time,
because it's a
convenient rule to have.
I'm going to prove the
second one, just again,
just to show you have
nothing to worry about.
You don't even have to remember
how the proof goes, of course,
you can reconstruct
it every time.
So it's again simple proofs
just by linearity of expectation
and doing the algebra.
So the variance of r is by
definition the expectation
of r minus mu squared.
Let's expand our
minus mu squared.
It's the expectation
of r squared
minus 2mu r plus mu squared.
Now we apply linearity to that.
I get the expectation
of r squared
minus 2mu expectation of r, plus
the expectation of mu squared,
if I'm really being
completely mechanical
about linearity of expectation.
Now expectation of a constant
mu squared is simply mu squared.
And here, I've get
the expectation
of r, that's mu again.
So I wind up with the
expectation of r squared
minus 2mu mu plus r squared.
This is 2mu squared-- minus
2mu squared plus mu squared.
It winds up with
minus mu squared.
And of course, mu squared is
the expectation squared of r,
I've proved the formula.
Again, as claimed, there's
nothing interesting here,
just algebra and
linearity of expectation.
And the first result
about factoring out an a
and squaring it follows
from a similar proof, which
I'm not going to include here.
So let's look at the
space station Mir
again, which we used as
an example of calculating
mean time to failure.
So the hypothesis
that we're making
is that with probability
p, the Mir space station
will run into some huge space
garbage that will clobber it.
And the probability of that
happening in any given hour
is probability p.
So we know that that means
the expected number of hours
for the Mir to fail
is 1 over p, that's
the mean time to failure.
And what we're asking is what's
the variance of f, if f is
the number of hours to failure?
What's the variance of f?
Well, one way we can
do is just plug-in
the definition of expectation
and this will work.
The probability that it
takes k hours to fail
is-- we know the
geometric distribution.
The probability of not
failing for k minus 1 hours,
and failing after that, q
to the k minus 1 times p.
So the variance of f,
using our previous formula
about the expectation
of f squared
minus the expectation squared
of f, this becomes a minus 1
over p squared.
We can forget
about that, we want
to focus on calculating the
expectation of f squared.
So f is 1, 2, 3, and so on.
That means f squared
is 1, 4, 9, k squared.
The point being that the
only values that f squared
can take our
squares, so we don't
have to worry about
counting them in to sum
that defines the expectation.
So let's go look at that.
So the expectation of
f squared is the sum
over the possible values
that f squared can take,
namely the sum from k equals
1 to infinity of k squared,
times the probability that f
squared is equal to k squared.
Well of course, the
probability that f
squared is equal to k squared
is the same as the probability
that f equals k.
And we know what
the probability of f
equals k is, it's a
geometric distribution, so
the probability that f equals k
is q to the k minus 1 times p.
If I factor out a p over q, this
simplifies to the sum from k
equals 0 to infinity of
k squared, q to the k.
And this is a kind
of sum that we've
seen before that
has a closed form
and we could perfectly
well calculate then
the expectation of f squared
by appealing to our generating
function information to
get a closed form for this,
and then remember to
subtract 1 minus p squared
because the variance is
this term minus the square
of the expectation of f.
But let's go another way
and use the same technique
of total expectation
that we used before.
That is, the expectation of
f squared, of the failure
of time squared, is equal, by
the law of total probability,
to the expectation of f
squared, given that f is one.
That is, we fail f
on the first step,
times the probability that
we fail on the first step.
Plus, the expectation
of f squared,
given that we don't
fail on the first step,
that f is greater than 1,
times the probability that f
is greater than 1.
Now, what's going to
make this manageable
is that this expression, the
expectation of f squared when
f is greater than
1, will turn out
to be something
that we can easily
convert into a
nonconditional probability,
and find a value for.
So the limit that we're
using here is the following.
What I'm thinking
about in mean time
to failure-- if I think of
any function whatsoever,
g of the mean time to failure.
And I'm interested in the
expectation of g of f,
given that f is greater than n.
That is, it's already taken
n steps to get where I am.
Then the thing about
the mean time to failure
is that at any moment
that you haven't failed,
you're starting off in
essentially the same situation
you were at the beginning in
waiting for the next failure
to occur.
And the probability of
failing in one more step
is the same probability--
is the same p.
And the probability
of you're failing
in two more steps is qp,
and three more steps is qqp.
The only difference
is that the value of f
has been shifted by n.
In the ordinary
case, we start off
with f equals 0 and
look at the probability
that we fail in one more
step, two more steps.
Now we're starting off with
f having the value f plus n,
and asking about the
probability that it
fails in the next step or the
next step, or the next step.
So the punchline is that
the expectation of g of f,
given that f is greater than
n, is simply the expectation
of g of f plus n.
And I'm going to let
you meditate that
and not say anymore about it.
But the punchline
is the corollary
that the expectation
of f squared,
given that f is greater than
1, is simply the expectation
of f plus 1 squared.
And that lets us go back and
simplify this expression.
That we've had from
total expectation,
we now have-- here's the
expectation of f squared,
given that f is greater than 1.
And let's look at
these other terms.
This is the expectation of f
squared, given that f equals 1.
Well, the expectation of f
squared given that f equals 1
is 1 squared, because
we know what f is
and that's the end of the story.
Times the probability
that f equals 1,
that's p, the probability
of failure on a given step.
This is the probability that f
is greater than 1, which is q,
that we didn't fail
on the first step.
And we just figured out that
this term is the expectation
of the square of f plus 1.
So there's the 1 and the p.
And that becomes a q, and
this is the expectation
of f plus 1 squared.
Now again, I apply
limit linearity.
I'm going to expand
f plus 1 squared
into f squared plus
2f plus 1, and then
apply linearity of expectation.
And I'm going to wind up with
the expectation of f squared
plus twice the expectation
of f, which remember,
is twice over-- 2 over
p, plus 1, times the q.
And now what I've got is a
simple arithmetic equation
between the expectation
of f squared
and some other arithmetic and
the expectation of f squared.
It's easy to solve for the
expectation of f squared.
And I'll spare you that
elementary simplification.
But the punchline
is, when-- we also
remember to subtract
one over p squared,
because that was the
expectation of the square of f
of the expectation of f.
We came up with this
punchline formula.
The variance of
mean time to failure
is 1 over the probability
of failure on a given step,
times 1 minus 1 over--
times the probability-- 1
over the probability of the
failure in the first step,
minus 1.
That's just for
practice and fun,
let's look at the space
station Mir again.
Suppose that I tell you that
there is a 1 in [? 10,000ths ?]
chance that in any given hour,
the Mir is going to crash
into some debris that's
out there in orbit.
So the expectation of f is 10 to
the fourth, about 10,000 hours.
And the sigma is going to be the
variance of f, which is about 1
over ten thousandths, that is
10,000 times 10,000 minus 1,
which is pretty close to 10,000
squared for the variance.
And when I take the square
root, I get back to 10,000.
So sigma is just a tad less than
10,000, is 10 to the fourth.
So with those numbers, I can
apply the Chebyshev's Theorem
and conclude that the
probability that the Mir lasts
more than 4 times 10
to the fourth hours
is less than 1 chance in four.
If we translate that into
years-- if it was really
the case that there was a 1 in
10,000 chance of the Mir being
destroyed in any given
hour, then the probability
that it lasts more than 4.6
years before destructing
is less than 1/4.
So another rule for
calculating variance,
and maybe the most
important general one,
is that variance is additive.
That is, the variance of a sum
is the sum of the variances.
But unlike expectation,
where there's no other side
condition, and it does not in
any way depend on independence,
it turns out that
variance is additive
only if the variables being
added our pairwise independent.
Now you might wonder where
the pairwise came from,
and it's because variance is
the square of an expectation.
So when you wind up multiplying
out and doing the algebra,
you're just getting
quadratic terms
for variances of-- for
expectations of ri times rj.
And so you need to factor those
into expectation of r times
expect-- ri times
expectation of rj,
which you only need
pairwise independence for.
So that's a fast talking
through the algebra
that I'm going to leave to you.
It's in the text, and it's
again one of these easy proofs.